all right here he is aaron rodgers
green bay packer maybe hopefully
god willing raiding mvp
all right we'll find that we'll get the
bearish break
there are bears here
middle
good job easy game
pretty solid right there i gotta say you
want to make to make me cut those all
day
long yeah i don't mind okay okay good
luck
i played with aaron when i was president
and
he hit some bombs uh you know so he's
obviously a great athlete
but let's see uh let's see how he teased
it up this time
actually still not a bad place to be
good swing dude
oh he's walking oh he's walking inside
nice thank you
[Laughter]
after they won the first hole
wow great shot great job
good shot come on back nice shot partner
great shot oh well done by all
guys how do i earn hit a good one good
job bro all right good stuff
here's aaron rodgers now let's trace it
good shot should be all right just threw
a little bit
oh yeah you're alive nice drive dude
good shot man nice drive partner
it's for eagle
trying to get it back to even oh my
goodness took a peek
great putt bro that was so good dude
thanks great putt
[Music]
[Applause]
that was hammered stay left it was way
over
oh there she is great drive man bye
sarin
is it right there it's beautiful wow
thanks guys all right great shot it's
about a 230
foot drop got the driver going for it
yeah that's what i'm talking about
partner oh yeah there she is
good drive i'm gonna knock it on that in
the fairway
sit in the fairway good job good shot
well if a guy hadn't been playing much
trevor he is really swinging well
nice ball partner it's so good man
it's that low bullet that should be okay
oh my goodness it should be
bounce right just like the last one
partner behind rotate
crush it rogers for birdie
good
is
yeah this to go three up
with six to play rogers for birdie
hurry
get there speed sit sit get there sit in
there
good speed that's my partner bro yeah
really nice
he's got some swagger right now aaron
rodgers to win the match
there it is that away partner let's go
partner yep come here
great job way to go tom thank you thank
you guys good plan great playing man
great playing thanks a lot thanks for
being here thank you hope you're not
ready for football season like this
yeah we'll see it's gonna be tough
enough this week